♪ We are Farmers. Bum-pa-dum,
bum-bum-bum-bum ♪
>> Tucker: TONIGHT IN THE LAST
INSTALLMENT OF WHAT WE CALL THE
TECH TYRANNY SERIES, WE LOOK AT
FACEBOOK.
FACEBOOK ALREADY KNOWS A
TERRIFYING AMOUNT ABOUT YOU.
MORE THAN YOUR PARENTS DO.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE HAPPY OR
ANXIOUS OR DEPRESSED.
WHEN YOU'RE FALLING IN LOVE AND
DO, BUT THEY WANT MORE THAN
THAT.
FACEBOOK REPORTEDLY SOUGHT
ANONYMOUS MEDICAL RECORDS FROM
SEVERAL U.S. HOSTILES FOR
UNKNOWN RESEARCH PURPOSES.
OF COURSE, NOT JUST A FACEBOOK
WILL GET THAT INFORMATION.
TODAY THE COMPANY ADMITTED THAT
MOST OF ITS 2 BILLION USERS,
MOST HAVE HAD THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION TAKEN BY UNNAMED
MALICIOUS ACTORS, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS, BUT IS NOT GOOD.
BEVERLY HALLBERG JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I THOUGHT MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT MEDICAL INFORMATION IS
PROTECTED.
HOW WOULD FACEBOOK GO ABOUT
GETTING THAT?
>> BY SIGNING A DOCUMENT EVERY
TIME YOU GO IN, MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING IS PROTECTED.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THEY GET AROUND
THIS AND THAT'S WHAT'S SO SCARY
ABOUT THIS.
I KNOW THAT MOST OF US EXPECT
WHEN THEY PUT SOMETHING ON
FACEBOOK, WHATEVER INFORMATION
YOU PROVIDE, WE EXPECT THAT TO
BE OUT THERE, BUT TO HAVE
FACEBOOK GOING TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS, HOSPITALS,
DOCTORS, TRYING TO FIND
INFORMATION ON YOU, I'M NOT SURE
HOW THAT'S EVEN ALLOWED.
THE ONLY THING I CAN THINK OF IS
THAT SINCE THEY WERE CLAIMING
ANONYMOUS, YOU HAVE TO PUT A
NAME TO THE MEDICAL RECORD THAT
SOMEHOW THAT WAS ALLOWED.
WHAT MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS NEED
TO KNOW IS THAT FACEBOOK KNOWS
HOW TO FIND OUT WHO THIS PERSON
IS.
THEY CAN EASILY ATTACH WHAT THEY
ARTY KNOW ABOUT YOU ON FACEBOOK.
>> Tucker: THIS INFORMATION
HAS TO BE INCREDIBLE EVALUABLE.
>> THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH 22
SELL ADS, THAT'S ALL FACEBOOK
MAKES ITS MONEY.
WE HAVE TO MOVE TO VIRTUAL
ADVERTISING BECAUSE TV IS NOT
THE SAME AS IT USED TO BE, BUT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A COMPANY
THAT IS SEEKING OUT INFORMATION
YOU NEVER THOUGHT THEY COULD
HAVE.
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
YOURSELF, IF YOU HAVE FACEBOOK
OPEN AT A HOSPITAL, THEY WOULD
KNOW YOU'RE THERE.
GPS LOCATORS, THEY WOULD KNOW
HOW TO FIND OUT WHICH HOSPITAL
YOU ARE AT IN ORDER TO CONNECT
THE DATA THAT THE HOSPITAL MAY
HAVE GIVEN TO YOU TO WHAT YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE ON YOUR PHONE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY DAMAGING.
YOU THINK ABOUT DOCTORS OFFICES,
THEY ASK IF YOU OWN GUNS.
THINK ABOUT THE MEDICAL